bring in joe contra fox news contributor
joe you heard alexandria's peace there
there's a reason heidi heitkamp is
former north dakota senator she's
literally from north dakota that's where
the oil comes from yet she has an
attitude like that but wait there's more
jennifer rubin of the washington post
tweeting this voters in a stupid
nutshell according to abc news ipsos
data 70 disapprove of biden's handling
of gas prices though even more
respondents 77 percent support his
proposal to ban russian oil even if it
means paying more at the pump common
theme from both of those statements to
me joe is that it is our fault not the
fault of the administration why is the
middle class always to blame when it
comes to these elites
a middle class and and obviously even
folks poorer than that todd who can't
afford these sort of
price increases at the pump because then
they're also making a decision perhaps
between uh gas and food right because
inflation is hitting that sector as well
uh or their home heating costs which
which have gone up in some cases 50
percent uh so yeah this is obviously
somebody who lives uh in in the ivory
towers of of the washington post or near
there in washington uh obviously elitist
is is jen ruben she once said actually
todd believe it or not she called for
rules that would prohibit media outlets
from treating republicans as normal
this is not a well person uh hillary
clinton by the way she once called trump
supporters a basket of deplorables right
and that worked out great uh look here's
what joe biden promised as a candidate
all right quote no more drilling on
federal lands no more drilling offshore
no ability for the oil industry to drill
period and as president he killed
drilling in anwar in alaska about five
minutes into his presidency he killed
the expansion of the keystone xl
pipeline as you guys have been talking
about and he continued his rhetorical
war on u.s oil companies accusing them
of price gouging and now they're
actually saying oh but can you help us
out before we try to destroy your
industry uh it's it's amazing so that's
where we are at this point uh jen rubin
who is the conservative columnist the
washington post defending joe biden at
every turn and quite frankly making a
fool of herself joe we've talked a lot
about kamala harris's trip to poland
where she laughed while while discussing
ukrainian refugees here's how an msnbc
panel described that moment watch this
she was strong she was assertive and
let's not forget this is the woman in
the senate who had senator shook this is
somebody who is used to kind of taking
on bad guys uh you know for a living
and it's like joe they were watching
something entirely different than the
rest of america
it's an interesting analysis carly right
at one point uh they said that kamala
harris shook
senators or shook bill barr the former
attorney general shook brett kavanaugh
during senate hearings so of course the
implication is that vladimir putin is
now shaking why because the vice
president awkwardly answered a question
about uh ukrainian refugees by saying a
friend in need is a friend indeed you
half expect her to add the third part of
that song which is a friend with weed is
better and then she proceeded
to cackle after that
look uh look she read some notes about
serious consequences for putin and
russia and as you can see the insidious
evil actions of putin says otherwise in
the whole shaking department he
continues to target civilians and
mothers journalists obviously as you
just talked about and and it doesn't
appear to be showing any signs of
stopping only increasing despite how
strong kamala harris looked during her
visit to poland guys
all right joe thank you so much for
joining us once again we will see you
tomorrow
okay that song is uh by placebo by the
way from 1998 the friend of need and
friend indeed
you're working out later carly and todd
it's so it's it's excellent todd knows
it probably a little before your time
i'm sure america was wondering good joe
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not gonna miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now